the technical term for these things is
transmission towers but here in Britain
we call them pylons and we've got tens
of thousands of them across the country
the First National Grid was built in the
inter War years and it was the largest
peacetime construction project Britain
had ever seen a single power Network
across the country pylons became part of
the landscape of Britain just as they
had around the world despite the
objections of many land owners
traditionalists and Poets these exist
because overhead lines are a fraction of
the price of underground cables and
they're much much easier and faster to
maintain if there's a fault you don't
need to bring in heavy equipment and dig
anything up instead you dispatch a team
to climb and that team will have learned
the job here at the National Grid
training center near erring in the East
Midlands and today one of those teams is
going to take me up on the wires so here
at the training center we have over 300
graduates and apprentices training in
overhead lines and substation
Technologies the team that have trained
here Will take a range of roles they
might be overhead line operators so they
be climbing Towers responding to faults
they also conduct visual inspections we
have a team of drone and helicopter
Pilots that keep the network operating
and then we have substation teams as
well so they would look at cleaning and
replacing different equipment within our
substations I haven't looked at any
point out or down to see how high I am
I'm just kind of going there's the next
bolt there's the next bolt and I'm aware
that the professionals are doing this
much faster than me I'm fine with that
we have a team of 2,400 people that
monitor and operate maintain the network
Around the Clock 24/7 this might be in
response to weather or faults on the
network and they keep the energy flowing
presumably you're up here in all
weathers you'll have dealt with rain and
snow in emergencies we're definitely uh
working bad weather you just take one
more step up yeah we attach you on to
the actual Tower give you a bit more
space thank
you oh it's not a bad view either is it
yeah it's not bad around here so what
this is first arm yep bottom phase
middle phase top phase huh it's
different phase of power on each arm
yeah right that makes sense cuz
otherwise the three would kind of
interact with each other on the wires so
we have 22,000 pylons each pylon weighs
approximately 30 tons 4 and a half th000
miles of overhead line and 900 mil of
underground cable because we're at our
training school we've got all different
combinations of of wires in different
formations we've got our new towers the
yeah the te pylons pons yep which aren't
as high no they're a bit lower keep
climbing oh it's getting real windy now
doing good time if you're wondering this
is the point where the nerves kicked in
I don't know if that's coming across on
microphone and camera but the wind is
whistling through the metal and through
the
wires okay well done Tom thank you
there's plenty of people who don't get
up here on the
head oh how's
that we own and operate the network in
England and Wales we also operate parts
of Scotland this training center was
built in the heart of the country
because a lot of the power stations were
around here in the Midlands in
because a lot of the coal that fueled
those power stations was being dug up
around here not all of it there was
plenty in Scotland and tinside and South
Wales too and a cluster of power
stations down on the temps but if you
were going to pick a spot in the center
of the power grid to have the best
access of every pylon you'd pick here
but things are changing and have been
changing for decades the only Coal Fired
station left in Britain it's about an
hour south on the other side of
Nottingham and that close down within a
year the main replacement right now is
gas and those stations tend to be on the
coast where enormous tankers of liquid
natural gas can dock the nuclear plants
are by the coast too for easy access to
cooling water and then there's the wind
Britain is a Windswept Island and we
already get a quarter of all our power
from the wind with half of that from
colossal fields of turbines offshore and
there are more and more and more of
those being built Britain's entire power
grid has been steadily turning inside
out for years as anyone who lives in a
former coal mining Community like this
knows all too well power generation just
isn't happening here anymore electricity
isn't being pushed out from the center
instead it's being brought in from the
coast all right next St down on the
wires going to be honest with you that
ladder is swaying a lot more than I'd
like I I'm going to go down first I'll
get it a lot more stable for you thank
you National Grid's role is to move
energy around the country we don't
generate energy we just connect it to
our Network it's weird to see all this
infrastructure not hear the bu I mean I
guess if you hear the buzzing and you're
on here you're really in trouble but in
total today we have 65 gaw of generation
connected to the network that's a whole
range of sources so we have about 90
sources of generation and the government
has a Target to connect an additional 50
gaws of offshore Wind by 2030 oh step
down okay like it's any normal ladder a
lot of meters above the ground that's
fine the ladder is angled the wrong way
my arms are further back than my legs in
order to connect the 50 gaws of offshore
wind that we're seeing out at Sea we
need to create a series of subsy cables
new overhead lines in order to move that
energy across the network as it stands
we know that we need to construct five
times as much infrastructure in the next
seven years as we have in the last 30 so
if you you just stop there for two
seconds yep you can stand on this and
it's pretty secure that was fun
okay okay one foot on each wire whenever
you feel comfortable you're perfectly
fine all
right wow it's all pretty sturdy stuff
you didn't have to prove that by
bouncing
[Laughter]
though it's impossible to disentangle
politics from the power grid when the
National Grid was first built the
government had to ignore so many
complaints to push it through but the
benefits were obvious and even the folks
who rallied against pylons would have to
admit that the result was probably worth
it compared to no electricity but now
and over the next few years there are
going to be political fights and
protests large and small because For the
First Time in nearly a century there are
some big and tough decisions to be made
about
pylons